asd superintendent dr jesus jarrah met  virtually with parents today  the number one question is when can kids  return to the classroom  now there is no set date but dr jarrah  gives a little insight into how the  decision making works  these are things whether it's coveted or  non-covered  whether it's distance at or face-to-face  right now  these are open because parents are  seeing it face to face and  virtually not face to face they're  seeing it firsthand  and and we're going to work on that and  we'll continue to cover it the schools  have been working on changing all  filters and keeping track of  logs to make sure there's proper  ventilation dr jarrah said a lot of work  has been done around hvac systems and  added they need to work  on showing those improvements to parents